well first angelina and brooklyn i like
to do a head and a heart check because
we're in this crazy
kind of time and space right now and i'm
going to start with you brooklyn because
are you secluded with your family are
you isolating with your family
yes what has been your favorite way to
pass this time because it's been a long
time
my brother keeps me pretty busy
sometimes sometimes i just get
really annoyed with him she's just like
i love you bb and i'm like okay give me
a hug
oh i
am we grew a garden and it's starting to
blossom
all our flowers failed so we planted
ones that already grew
and um we're harvesting some of the
vegetables which is really nice
um i've kept myself busy my mom and dad
are showing me great movies
yeah i've been sometimes it's been
really boring
yeah but it sounds like you're making
the best of a really crazy situation
so i'm glad to hear that and angelina i
wonder are you
like finding the silver lining that all
your kiddos are back in one space
together or are you like
after five months ooh child i am the
mother of six
you know i'm so lucky that we've all
been used to being
tight together for a long time and it
was so nice when matt
came home from college even though i'm
so happy he's there now he's going to be
going to college in korea
while he's still in the house so i
somehow ended up with even though it's
at 6 00 p.m
but yeah he starts late but you know i
i'm i'm lucky and i think when you have
that many children
they they really take care of each other
they help me i'm not
i'm not alone managing everything they
are
an amazing team so i'm very very
fortunate
i love that um it sounds like
everybody's winning all the way around
over here that's good because it can be
tough this time can be tough and and so
i'm glad to know that everybody's in
good spirits
[Music]
my sister where's your sister now i
don't remember
memories never leave us they just get
out of reach
let's talk about this movie because um
number one i think it's a movie that we
need
in right now and number two it's so
adorable so
brooklyn i want to start with you when
did you first fall in love with this
story
well i fell in love with it when um i
found out about the script
and my mom bought me the book well i
don't know
yeah my grandma bought me the book
because we went to the mall and she
and we found it on like the top shelf
and
in the back of barnes and nobles and
we're like yes
and so i read it and i absolutely
fell in love with the story it's
something that's
not predictable like the end to me
wasn't really predictable
and it was something that was really
warm and it left you with
a warm feeling inside how about you
angelina when did you
really fall in love with this this tale
well shiloh years ago
told me that she'd read a book that she
loved and she wanted me to read it
and so we wow we didn't read it together
i read it on my own and then we looked
at some of
it together and we talked about why she
loved it and
um and then i inquired if it was being
made as you do into a film
and i found that it was kind of in the
works but kind of hadn't figured out so
i tried to stay with it and push it to
stay as true to the book as possible
that was my main focus
and um i just think it's a very very
special
uh it's a very special story it's a very
it's a true story
so of course it's an important true
story and i think that resonates with
with all of us right and and especially
with the environmental issues and the
destruction of these these natural
habitats
and poaching and what you know um
and we have young people who are
activists now and
aware of these issues and at the heart
of this film is also a young activist
who can see what the adults can't see
and then we have also a central
character in ivan who is saying this is
your perception of me
what you think you know of me you think
i'm supposed to be this
that's not who i am and will i be
allowed to be who i am
and i think that's how everybody feels
in many ways yeah there's a lot
did shiloh when did she like connect to
it more than the other kids did she
introduce it to everybody else or
yeah is she that that girl she was the
one with this one yeah
it's interesting that you talk about
some of the themes in the movie because
there were
so many good ones but a couple of them
that sat with me like they sat with you
was
number one it's never too late to figure
out who you are
you know and and then also um finding
your people
your village finding you know your crew
and i think that really sits with me now
in this time and space when you really
gotta check in and check on your people
know who you who your
your folks are why do you think this is
going to resonate so much especially i
guess now
with audiences well i think you're right
there is something to
you know we had when we were in when we
made this film we hadn't we we talked
about it
and the captivity of the animals we
talked about the space we talked about
the lack of freedoms or the
family and the the coming together and
and the judgment and things but we
didn't we didn't know what when it would
be coming out we didn't understand and
and it being something that is seen at
home where a lot of people
are feeling confined
trying to hold on to their friends
trying to you know really checking
themselves
um trying to better themselves trying to
you know understand the world around
them it is coming
at a at a different time and and i hope
it does really resonate with people and
also gives them some sense of hope
because
a big part of this is is looking at what
you do have
and and then helping others
and and knowing that like you said there
and the
story says you know that there's it's
never too late to really discover who
you are
and to push forward with that person and
to better
to be a better person yeah that choice
and uh and it is a hopeful the real
ivan did did have a nice a nice end
to it after a very difficult life did
ruby did what she was going through and
her journey kind of sit with you
as a you know young person really kind
of trying to figure out
your own voice and lane in life and and
what you love
and you know to get over your fears and
insecurities
well um i really
kind of knew who i was i kind of
know who i am right now i'm pretty
confident in who i
am and what i believe in um
and but i feel like ruby also taught me
yes to face my fears
i mean ruby's perspective is just so
fresh and new
isn't she she hasn't gone through much
in life except for being
taken away from her home and she hasn't
she's been through a lot even though
she's
well she has been through a lot but she
hasn't been through
all like her whole life and she hasn't
had tons of experiences and
she's learning about what life is like
and you know
how she deals with it it cannot she
taught me
a different way to deal with it like
when she is
sad and she had just been taken away
from her home she asked
questions and she opens up about it and
she really
sort sorta looks at it like a
i need to ask questions about it like
she asks it
i love that can you tell me quickly the
story of these
elephant onesies because i heard that's
a good story
well the story of the elephant onesies
is we saw each other at critics choice
and it was the second time i had seen
angie
and i said hey why don't we
wear elephant onesies uh
on in adr and she was like
sure and i go home and i'm like mom
please buy me an angie elephant onesies
we're gonna wear elephant onesies
i'm buying an elf on onesie for angelina
jolie
you think okay okay what's going on okay
we get it all sorted out on the day she
shows up
wearing which she shows up and she's
like hey
look at that before me and so he pulls
on our elephant onesie and we took a
selfie
and we rocked them the rest of the day
but it got hot so we just tied them
around our waist
angelina it made that makes me fall in
love with you even more
i love a woman who loves an elephant
onesie how could you say no to that